[Music]
all right you guys know how
a.i is being used a lot in our
day-to-day i like you with those glasses
thank you
it's hot do i look smart those are nice
and then they match the wait maybe
is there another pair okay oh yeah
there's okay sorry i got distracted the
nikkies are wearing glasses now i got
distracted by them
very estudious and joe non 20 20 vision
now it's quite foggy
bart don't do that it's not the same
part
scary so what are you talking about
so um okay yeah so you know how ai's
being used to like make our lives easier
and everywhere and do a lot of things
right
well in sports a lot of
a lot of them they've decided to use ai
instead of actual human cameramen
to reduce the spread of covert and all
that stuff oh for real
cameramen are getting let go i know
right so there's cameras on like
dollies and then they move according to
where they think the players are going
yeah so they're actually following the
ball
and so this particular so in this
particular story
it's a soccer game in scotland and this
ai
was tracking the ball
but one of the referees was bald-headed
he looked like a soccer ball so then the
ai kept
like oh
we are not going to get killed by the
robots that's what i just heard or
all soccer balls are going to get killed
with us okay that sucks
and diesel the rock all those guys are
getting killed they're out there oh my
god
but they go before me at least yeah true
just barely
just barely all right so i'm going to
show you guys a video clip it's like a
racquetball
like what's it the one the the wiffle
ball don't know the uh
i'm a foosball batman you're a badminton
the only it's a birdie random [ __ ] i
know
i just think about you got some hair you
know when the face
see i'm on tick tock and i'll be
watching like these dancing videos
and they go like this um the sensor so
you have to like
look at it and it'll track your head and
it bounces around that's all i can think
about is like the camera
going like this and doing dance moves
yeah all right so here's a video clip of
this match
so it's following the ball it's like
centenary and then here's the referee
and the ball's over here oh my god
they're just glitching it's just like
yeah it just starts following that head
oh yeah so they're gonna be like uh you
have to put a hat on
even the way the light bounces off it is
very shiny oh it's the same
wrap what is the ref think he's probably
pissed he's like listen
what are you supposed to do about this
no and then the hilarious part which i
don't have
but they were writing on twitter people
that actually saw this game live that
they were saying that the announcer guy
kept having to apologize
for the ai and say loop sorry oh
wait why can't they have a camera guy up
there like so far away
wait that doesn't make sense maybe
they're just like testing it out
yeah i guess they're super social
distance that's about as social distance
as you can get that's like a sniper
distance
that's true yeah it's not even in your
face well why don't they do like
football
don't they have the camera that's on the
stream i love that [ __ ] yeah
nba and nfl have been killing it with
the way that they've been
it's been amazing do you think the
players though are affected by
like the the vibe of the crowd for sure
right
there's no home field advantage anymore
dude no it's like it's like practicing
it's like running it's like
it's like a pickup game at the park now
yeah don't they play at least like some
fake audio yeah
well for us but not in stadium oh i
thought it wasn't stadium
no no so um for baseball they play
sounds they actually play the sounds in
the stadium
they do no they do like i think somebody
is sitting with like a sound like a
little keyboard and like
if you're that player you're just
looking at the keyboard guy like
one guy yeah i know there's only one guy
that can actually look at it are you
just an entire crowd he's like
bob really that's not my [ __ ] theme
song they do that for us they do that
for football though too but they play it
into the camera
at home people but so one of the
interesting things that's going on right
now in football is they can hear
everyone's signals and snap counts and
hard counts oh
so they've been making them up i don't
know what that means all the secret talk
right so like aaron rodgers is the green
bay packers quarterback right and he has
like a very um unique like hard count
when he's about to
snap the ball and now everyone can hear
it and so but he's able to use
that also to mind [ __ ] the defense super
interesting well because
so before when they started when they
when they started miking up players it
was uh
for i want to say hbo or one of the
networks was teaming up they were
teaming up with the nfl during the
camps so they would make knocks yes so
that people could start understanding
what it's like to actually be on the
field and so
so one of the things is it's such an
advantage to know
what your other what your opponent does
the play's going to be you can throw him
off if his hard count is a certain way
and you go and do something what's the
hard count
yeah explain so when he's about to snap
the ball right he's like for the people
blue 42 hot hot hot hug right
but the way his cadence is with his def
or with his offensive line
so even though he did three so he so i
picked up he only did three huts
because i play sport because i play
sports so three would mean something
else if he did two that means
exactly and then even the names the
names that he says
what's another name omaha peyton manning
omaha
set hut right all that [ __ ] it means it
so it could mean
change to a run play he he could say
wait don't they don't they discuss this
before they go on the phone
not the opponents though you're you're
the other people that's why when you see
them
on the field they're like the the guys
calling the place the coaches that are
like offensive coach defensive coach
specialty whatever
um have you ever yes so
you can hear the quarterback can hear
everything until yeah they can hear
everything
that the coach is saying until like a
nascar racer until the play clock
reaches a certain
when they run too far away the bluetooth
cuts off and they can't hear anything
or like in baseball there really are
phones or there are ways to communicate
with the people up top because they're
reading
like they're reading signs your catcher
when they're doing something or they're
doing these like
signs they're fingerprinting so once you
can pick up like a
coach's signals you as a player know
what's coming
and you can actually shift so there's
people that sit and they call
shifts so they'll tell you like shift
left shift right because that's where
the player is supposed to be hitting the
ball so like a jj watt or somebody like
who's really good at
the leader of his own defense he'll be
he'll hear and rogers go kill kill and
then he will
start to change the way that the defense
is lined up to
to make up for what he thinks aaron
rodgers is going to do if that makes
sense but it's don't try to anticipate
yeah yeah but it's dope for us yeah it's
super cool for the people watching
because you're like oh [ __ ] that's what
he's doing and that's why they're
there's so much more mental games going
on than people even though it's so fast
like a chess player strategy
totally yeah and baseball has that too
there's a lot of there's a lot to do
with these sports because soccer doesn't
have any of that it's
very boring do you guys watch like the
it is boring the leaked footage of like
basketball players the ones when they're
like when the camera's showing where the
ball is right
on the side there's like all these other
footage of like what's happening yeah so
when they're like guarding each other
they're actually elbowing each other
punching people in the face like there's
a lot like they're
talking like oh [ __ ] i own your mama
[ __ ] rape your mom they're saying
crazy yeah or like i mess with your
girls
basketball you just don't see it because
they're following the ball but on the
sides people grabbing their nuts
and tripping them water polo needs
cameras if water polo
underneath yes water polo needs
underneath football when they get all
get
in the pile like going for the ball
under there [ __ ] up [ __ ] is going on
they're like this
titty twisters and [ __ ] wait how is that
like sportsmanlike it's not
sportsmanlike
yeah the refs can't see it and they're
trying to [ __ ] with their mental game
half of it's mental part
i told you i slept with your man
while you're on the field you're gonna
be like this [ __ ] did what and then i'm
like this got you now i'm in my head and
i can't defend you and you just caught
the touchdown
so i'm like this or if all game long
like you're some veteran and i'm some
new kid and i'm like you [ __ ] you
actually [ __ ] suck and then i'm
actually catching balls on you
like it's getting in this guy's head
it's so i [ __ ] up my [ __ ] friend
for
from playing mario kart cuz he kept
talking [ __ ] i threw the remote at him
and i was like that's how i win [ __ ]
that's just violence i love that
monopoly did you watch uh last dance
last dance i'd be the banker stealing
money
uh this is the one part
where uh he scores this crazy ass shot i
think and then the other guy is like
[ __ ] man because everyone already
already knows the reputation of jordan
he goes i'm black jesus
and then so the other person's like oh
[ __ ] so now every time jordan comes on
the court he's like
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] black and he just
keeps doing the most amazing [ __ ] ever
so it's like
the game hasn't even started any lost
damn intimidation
i never knew that i've never been into
sports but this [ __ ] got me intrigued
that's why the mental game is yeah
that's why you have the press
conferences like uh wait oh why did why
did this person get into a car crash in
a dui like all the stuff
off the court plays into them you groom
them it's like boxing matches
essentially like every time you have the
two opponents and they meet up and they
square up and all the [ __ ] talking
that's literally mental games that's why
bill belichick is the greatest coach of
all time because
he will tell the media they're like
would you oh my god you guys just got
blown out in cincinnati he's like we're
on we're on to cleveland
we're on to cleveland so it's like a
reality tv show
why do you think lebron went every time
he came in because he was establishing
dominance i'm the [ __ ] i don't care
about you
you guys are all watching me i'm the
[ __ ] man be scared
well he wasn't even why they just won
either but he was but he was the leader
it so it doesn't matter that he was the
point scorer or any of that kind of
none of it mattered it's an attempt my
college coach
purposely picked four of the tallest
girls in order to go and meet up with
team so when you go with
positioning when you go and do a coin
toss um you're picking
who's gonna hit first you know who's you
know home and away and whatever
and he said i pick you
because you're tall and intimidating i
pick you because
you're ugly you're scary no michael
you're scary
my coach straight up said was like
you're scared like to one of the girls
like you're scared you intimidate them
and he's like
he used to call me habul he's like a
bull you brought all the boys over there
so they cheer every time you walk up
so uh you know we just want them to feel
some type of way when you come
but it's all right
coach cassidy used to actually uh work
with john madden
i want my my college coach coach cassidy
which i love he was one of the most
amazing human beings like he is one of
the most amazing human beings
what did you play softball he was my
softball coach and
he would always he was very strategic
but he worked with john madden at one
point in time writing with him and so
he brought a lot of he brought a lot of
that into the field so
all of those intimidation factors and
positioning and
you know okay she brings all the fans
okay they do this and they do that it
was it was pretty dumb i don't know john
madden is the maker of the john madden
video game that's it
that's all he did he didn't need it he
makes it every [ __ ] year
he makes it every single year that's all
he did that's what he did
you